well good evening we're balancing around
160,000 people who work in the public
sector that's right across the UK civil
service and all related public bodies
because these are members who have since
2010 I've had a two-year pay freeze and
then five consecutive years of pay
capped at 1% and what sort of jobs are
we talking about here what are the
things do they do well our members are
the unsung heroes and heroines of the UK
public service often not talked about
but keep Britain running so we're
talking about people who collect tax
people who secure our borders people who
pay our benefits people who run the
justice system in the courts the Crown
Prosecution Service people who keep our
roads safe and the highways agencies the
Coast Guard agency people who work in
the air traffic control so we're really
talking here about people who work not
just for government but related public
bodies who affect everybody's daily life
whether it's from culture paying
benefits or collecting tax and what sort
of pay increases you looking for well I
should be the first to say our union
fully supports our health workers I'm
recovering myself from a heart
transplant and I know firsthand how
marvelous the doctors nurses and porters
were on it thanks very much but we
believe that it's important here that
all public sector workers if I they pay
capped should now have in flesh and
proofed pay raises we think that that
should be at 5% and our independent
research tells us for example as civil
servants who are some of the lowest paid
public sector workers tens of thousands
owe in less than 20,000 pounds a year
for example have lost three and a half
thousand pounds in real terms since 2010
compared to inflation and that a five
percent increase would only go a small
way of actually bringing back some of
the money that they've lost but the
total public set to payroll weighs 180
billion pounds I mean five percent
that's an extra nine billion pounds that
the government has to come up with how
do you pay for that well first of all
you pay for it by politically accepting
that you put a value on your public
sector workers who keep the country
running well the cost needs to be found
by government I mean we make the case
that the pay cap is counterproductive in
economic terms because of course when
our members get pay raises they spend
the money and they help support the
economy but Theresa May found a billion
pounds to get the dup into government to
nine billion pounds us a couple of pence
on the income
tax well we believe that there's many
routes in which the money could be found
but first of all the government have to
accept that something has to be done and
when I wrote to Teresa may after the
general election because she has no
mandate for the public sector pay cap
I got a rude and insulting reply from
Damian green on her behalf that told us
our pay was really good and they were
capping paid to protect jobs and the
civil service has lost a hundred and
twenty thousand jobs since 2010 making
it the smallest has been since the
Second World War on a members living
standards are down by ten percent in
real terms but we still have a deficit
this year more than fifty billion pounds
on me we can't borrow any more money so
essentially you're calling for taxes to
go up well we're calling for the
government to make a priority of public
sector pay it has billions of pounds of
it's disposal and it should make this
priority now we make the case that for
example if the government was serious
about tackling the tax cap if you had an
economy that worked for all if it
actually prioritized it's frontline
public sector workers and the people who
keep the country running then that would
give us an economic boost at the end of
the day it's a political priority we
deserve better and we determine to fight
for it all right mark so Walker from the
PCs Union thank you for joining me good
see